[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation I could do the whole
hour on Kevin Kelly it would be an
interesting one to do actually he's done
a few unusual things he's biked across
America twice he's walked the
Appalachian Trail most of it says it's
pretty boring he spent 10 years instead
of being in college which he dropped out
in his freshman year walking all over
Southeast Asia and taking photographs
astonishingly all of which survived that
and he put out in a book called Asia
grace which is just photographs no
captions but there is a link to the web
and you go to the web and that's where
you find out about what's going on in
the pictures that's normal for Kevin he
is always up to something connected but
strange a lot of us who've known and
watching him slogging away on this book
what technology wants for years now have
been waiting to see pieces of it and
that's what we're seeing tonight
specifically looking at the history and
future of science Kevin Kelley
[Applause]
thank you it's wonderful to be on the
other side of this program what I want
to talk about is something that is very
important to us but we don't talk about
very much which is
science science produces the only news
but Israeli in the news itself I have to
have a sort of a long interest in
science I began as a kid I had a nature
museum in my basement when I was in
junior high school then I got a
chemistry set and I think perhaps I was
the most unusual chemistry set in
America
for a boy because I actually did not
make a bomb I never tried to blow
anything up I actually tried to make
nylon once I was trying to do
chromatography I was actually trying to
do cool stuff with with chemistry and
from there I went on into high school I
took I think every single science and
math class that my high school offered
but as Stuart said a little bit maybe
too prominently I dropped out of college
I found a little too boring as well and
I went to Asia where I basically awarded
myself an advanced degree in Asian
Studies and but all that time I kept
thinking well maybe maybe maybe I missed
out on science maybe I should have
really tried science and so I actually
invited myself to a friend who ran the
lab who is the professor University of
Georgia and he was doing a microbiology
lab and I went down to Georgia and I
worked in his lab where we were studying
lipids and I actually made a film with
him and this is that we made an
educational film on digestion and a note
about the white lab coats scientists do
not wear a white lab coats but we were
in a film and a guy who made the film
the sisters that we wear them so
it turns out that actually I'm a very
bad scientist I'm not I don't really
have that the patience and the
dedication that you need to do science
and so while I dropped out the guy I
worked with went on to greater things he
actually was studying lipids and getting
proteins across lipids and then he went
on to genetic as well and right now just
last month the FDA approved his
inhalable insulin that was his that was
his product and so now he's changing
lives and many people in the world but I
dropped out and I did the next best
thing which is that I married a
scientist so my wife was here dry mean
as a scientist at Genentech and she's a
biochemist and while I'm at home typing
up little reviews of the next best
bottle opener she's trying to cure
cancer and she also makes it very she
also makes it very clear that my
knowledge of molecular biology and
genetics is pretty pretty flip-flop and
but I still enjoy hanging around with
with scientists and talking to them and
so while I was at Athens and researching
one of the things that the reason why I
did not become a scientist was became
much more interested in what scientists
were doing rather than trying to study
that what the lipids were I became
really interested in how scientists
themselves were processing information
how did they know what to do how did
they get information themselves how did
they pass it around became much more
interested in the this in the science
process rather than the scientific work
and in fact I became so interested that
I actually wrote up a little article it
was one of the first articles that it
was published and it was called
information is a communicable disease
and not coincidentally it was published
in Stewart brands magazine at that time
called coevolution quarterly
and I was really interested in how
information is connected and the
connections between scientists and the
information that they generate and this
is a citation map from Jing Garfield
which was just trying to make a map of
the connections and the references
between scientists and so what happened
was I became really interested in
science from a once removed and I and
I'm not a scientist and I'm not even
really a science journalist really and I
because I don't even have enough of
in-depth knowledge about a certain field
to be a science journalist and so one
time I tried to figure out what is it
that I am and I finally have decided
that I am a science groupie I I like
hanging around scientists I like to hear
them talk shop I like to talk about
their science and most importantly a lot
like to talk about science itself and
that's interesting discussion because
you can talk to science and and the
fieldwork and the kind of work and the
results science have when you want to
talk to a scientist about science
they're clueless they look at you in a
big blank
they say if you ask them about you know
scientific method has changed it's not
going to be the same in the future
doesn't quite register the fact that
that we the way we do science will
change and so this is what I want to
talk about is how the scientific method
itself has changed over time and how it
will change into the future and I'm
really interested in serve those
long-term term trends about science
because I think that it's the foundation
of our culture it's the foundation over
Society and we really need to look at
that and I'm interested in for a couple
different reasons and so I know everyone
here is like to know about the next 100
years of science but before we can do
that we have to kind of figure out what
science is now a lot of people there a
lot of lists out there about the best
scientific inventions in the last 2,000
years and that's the kind of common way
people think about science and when the
list was was asked by Jon Brockman and
Connie answers he got was very
interesting because he asked some of the
most prominent scientists around the
world what were the most important
scientific inventions in the last 2,000
years and you get some very interesting
questions so the future of science as we
think about it is not dis okay that's
not what the future of science is really
about I want to talk about something
else the the kind of example that people
would give for the best invention in the
last 2,000 years would be something like
hey this was actually Freeman Dyson
suggestion who is who was working off of
Lynn white and others who said well you
know hey maybe it was domesticated made
possible the storage of animals over the
winters and then it was basically a part
of the agricultural revolution and that
in its way it further the development of
our culture with other things
another common reply is well penicillin
or antibiotics these were obviously
things that changed the course of
history paper what I mean paper was a
great invention right it allowed
printing and
money and that itself of course
transformed the our economy the rudder
was another example it allowed
navigation sports creation of the Seas
allowed the settlement of Micronesia and
Australia and it was very important in
changing the dynamics later on in terms
of empires or electricity of course that
that changed the role too but in each
one of these cases this is not what I'm
talking about I'm not talking about the
different little things that science
throws off and I'm trying to talk about
something else something more profound
and in some senses this is like the the
ideas of the brain throws off if you're
trying to really study the brain you're
not just look at the words that people
use or the words that people say or the
ideas that they that the brain has you
you wanted to study the dynamics of the
brain itself rather than the words that
are thrown off and so we try to think
about the categorizations of you if we
ask yourself is there a pattern to to
all the the scientific inventions of the
past the common way that we kind of line
them up is to say well we have some idea
of Stone Age Bronze Age iron steam we
can kind of see them in that way and
again this is not really I think very
helpful in trying to understand science
I went back to try to find out the first
conceptions of science when science was
first used and error in around a
thousand in the medieval era there were
seven Sciences and they were basically
types of desk work they were there were
a type of knowledge but they were things
that were done to the desk the very
first example I could find and that
whether first examples I could find of
the word science was used often
interchangeably with another word called
sapiens science and sapiens they were
both meant knowledge in fact it's
probably only a quirk of language that
Linnaeus didn't name us homo science it
could have just as easily because at
that time in the meat of and before his
time that was what the word meant in it
knowledge and it was not until the 1700s
science came to be seen as a word to
indicate a process of how we come to
knowledge and that's that word that has
taken on its meaning now that I'm most
interested in so the interesting aspect
about what we have when we have a
process is that it enables sustainable
long-term change that's what we get from
science over time is we have we have
changed that sustainable over long terms
and it's not at first what we think of
as civilization because there's
interesting thing about civilization is
that civilizations come and go okay
civilizations disappear and so we have
the sense in which a civilization is
kind of kind of calm can come up and
have a rain for a while then they go
away but science is much more of a
progressive sensibility there is
something else going on besides just the
fact that that we have a civilization in
fact I think the progressive nature we
have in civilization is comes from the
science part of it otherwise in the old
days before there was much science there
was a the appearance of civilization as
being more cyclic I have a map on my a
chart on my wall in my home office and
this is a map of the civilizations over
the last 5000 years and there's arranged
geographically and you can kind of get a
sense that there's really not a large
pattern there
so the aspect of science that I find
most interesting that I want to kind of
take a few minutes to talk about right
now
is is the the way in which science makes
connections and I think it's the
connections and relationships between
ideas and between facts and between
knowledge that actually give science its
character and its strength now I think
the fact that things are connected is
very very important because there is
it's sort of politically incorrect to
say that Columbus discovered America or
that Oscar Vaughn bring gay discovered
the gorillas in say in 1902 because
those were things that out see other
humans knew about but in fact fact I
think there is a way which is true
within science that those were
discoveries because what was happening
was we were taking some knowledge that
was very isolated before and we were
connecting it to all other things that
were known we were those those acts
brought in some information and they
were and it was being tied into and
related to everything else that was
known it was no longer isolated so the
information about the gorillas was was
kept very local was not hiding was not
referenced was not checked was not in
any way improved by the rest of the
knowledge that the world knew and that's
what science is doing so what these
things create is basically a structure
of sustainable changes and what these
connections do is they allow change to
happen in this stink way and as I
explored this idea of different ways and
different connections within science
there was one idea one necessary
connection I think I have to make clear
when one kind of technical idea and that
is this ok this this this is basically a
picture of recursion this is a recursive
thing where you can go right now it has
a sense that's going smaller and smaller
but you can go the other way you can
think of something that's bigger inside
something bigger and bigger and there
are many ways to do recursion this is
another way this is more interesting
because you can't really see the bubble
there's it kind of flows from what one
level flows into the
you're not really sure what's going on
of course I sure made this very very
famous in his his lithographs and of
course now we're into the territory of
douglas hofstadter who's been an entire
book kind of reflecting on the different
ways in which there's self reference
this is your Burroughs which is the
classical simple thing is it eating
itself is it is it inside the mouth or
outside the mouth and there's other ways
you could have a self reference which is
like a fractal where are the larger hole
references the the smaller parts that
they're identical in all different
scales but here's another way even
language has a way that's self
referenced this is this sentence is
false and so there is a sense in which
the sentence points back to itself and I
think that pointing back to itself is
very very profound and it's very
profound in science because what's
happening is that in that pointing back
to itself it it's referencing an
implicit other level that did not exist
before all right so when the sentence
goes back and points yourself you
suddenly you're out you're taking out of
it you're and and it's moved to another
level of meaning and that's happening in
every emergent system that I can really
think of is is is what happens is that
the the circle creates a new level and
outside experience or outside level that
would did not exist before and we have
the same thing happening in computer
programming recursion is a very common
pattern and then what gives the
robustness in a power to computer
programs is the fact that they are then
they can do this this is a map of the
genetic I'm excuse me the metabolic
pathway of pathways in a cell and it's
nothing but recursion and as well as
most genomes where they have genes
turning on other genes that turn on
other genes so you have this sense in
which things point back to themselves
and this pointing back creates another
level of existence or reference that did
not exist before
this is citation this is this is science
where you have authors citing other
authors who are citing other authors you
have this sort of web of citations and
interconnection
facts and and that is what science
generates is it generates paradox for
one thing these are paradoxical systems
because you don't know what's at the
bottom when things are kind of turning
around to themselves there's a sense of
emergence a new reference coming out
they're sustainable in the sense that
they keep things going to keep going
things around and around and they're
also it's about change ability here is a
wonderful sense of a wonderful instance
of recursion which is the US
Constitution Article five talks about
how you amend the Constitution so within
itself is something that points back to
the document self and so you have a
mechanism for how this is going to
change and that is actually I think the
power of this document is that it allows
sustainable change over time because it
has of rules for how it changes itself
it's pointing back to itself that change
ability that pointing back to itself is
it's a little game it's kind of sounds
fun it sounds trivial but in fact I
think it's actually the engine for
making this infinite game because it can
keep going as long as you're going back
to it you can kind of learn to changing
the rules that change the change you can
keep the system going forever so this
recursive game can be read in many
different ways you can say well science
is evolution of evolution itself how
evolution involves over time it's
exploring the ways to explore if favors
opportunities which create other new
opportunities or it's how you play the
game of playing all games
that's the infinite game and what's
interesting to me is that well if you
think about the the two the two large
systems that play in front of games
there's to them one science and the
other is religion and I'll come back to
that later but I think that that's the
background I want to go into the history
how science has changed over time
so first I would like to talk about the
origins of science then I'd like to talk
about the future and then most important
to me I like to talk about the meaning
of science so how does science change
over time well the first thing is there
were observations facts and then people
began to do this recursive thing you
have a bibliography you have a document
a book that basically references other
books and in that and and then one of
the first the the first indexes to other
books is actually very old the first
collections very very early have of
indexes to them then you had a catalogs
where they're actually where they're
actual listed the book itself is listed
in the list of other books libraries
with an index is another kind of same
thing where we're actually this is this
is a the imagination of virtual
rendering of what the Library of
Alexandria looked like they were Scrolls
so what's happening is we're starting to
structure this information more
collaborative encyclopedia where you
have more than one person more than one
source coming in to write a book
collectively kind of like open source
controlled experiment came along and of
course Roger Bacon was very instrumental
in that and suggesting the fact that you
want to have an experiment that you
could change the variable so here is
again another structuring of the
information the laboratories became
common where people decided to actually
do things in a controlled setting
against a structure of the information
coming out of it telescopes scopes other
things that were invented to allow more
data to come in to generate new data in
new ways by having new tools you can see
new things have new questions
this was another important advance in
the history of science the Society of
experts were again a collective people
would try and work on similar kinds of
questions and problems and exchange the
information between them so we have a
further structuring of that information
then Boyle was the first to propose that
the necessity of having a repeatable
experiment in his work with a cold pumps
and heat and cold he was saying you have
to be able to repeat an experiment in
order to make it valid so they were
adding another level of information and
structure scholarly journals came out
along the way and they started to pass
this information and put it into
documents and peer review would start
off as letters being passed between each
other where they were actually starting
to evaluate and to check and comment on
the work of others in a more organized
fashion and then the hypothesis and
prediction was coming in which came of
Newton trying to suggest well if this is
true then we should expect this again a
further structuring of this so all these
kinds of things I want to show in a
diagrammatical way these these notions
have no real meaning but we have a fax
we start a lot we have lots of facts we
start to add a bibliography around them
which takes the same thing so one of the
items is itself referring to others we'd
have a yeah that's a bibliography we
have a library that does the same thing
we begin to add other facts outside we
start to have new ways of seeing new
inputs scopes telescopes which bring in
more information which is then connected
with hypotheses and predictions which
evaluate and we have another one it's
repeatability we try it again over here
we add a society of experts which are
cross-referencing all these things are
to show you that we what we have with
science is information that's being
further and further structured and
organized more in to this century or
last century we have leave engine of the
falsifiable falsifiable testability
saying that something really cannot be
declared you can't really judge
something unless there's some way to
falsify it
that was popper and then the randomized
design which is that one of the ways
that you wanted to verify and add depth
to the kind of information doing is you
this was Fisher who said you have to
have you have to have a you have to be
careful of and be mindful of probability
and statistics that the
is an important component in fact you
can actually do things we take random or
statistical approaches to information
and then the controlled placebo the idea
of that you would actually have
basically a null set you would have zero
in an experiment and that would be the
control that it was a way again of
adding structure to it computer
simulations came along this was a very
big thing and then the double-blind
refinement of an experiment were you
actually the experimenter and the the
the the patient would also both be
ignorant of it again different ways in
which this information was being
structured and finally science itself
not not that late but this was a
representation of it the famous book of
the structure of scientific revolutions
suggesting that science itself was a
subject of study and that looks like
this okay there's recursion where you're
taking the whole mass of things and then
you're looking at it itself okay so my
my conclusion about all this is that
science is a way it's a process of
changing how we know that's about it's
about knowledge it's about sapiens it's
about it's about knowing and it's it's a
process for changing how we know things
okay so what that's really interesting
but I think what most everybody really
wants to know is what's the next
thousand years of science okay I mean
that's so one easy general answer is
well it's this okay it's more
structuring of information more
connections between things that we've
made and no more ways of knowing deeper
more complex things but what you really
wanna know is you know well when are we
going to have flying cars
right or robots that talk or maybe
virtual reality so let me tell you about
what when I write some of my
speculations are on the next hundred
years of science
so first I would say is that science is
going to change more in the next 50
years and it has in the past 400 years
as as as different as the scientific
method is now from the West forty years
ago
and bacon and boil and Newton it's going
to be even more different in the next 50
years 200 years okay because because
we're gonna continue to restructure how
we know about things and the process of
how we change how we know ok so the
second thing I would say is that it's
going to be a bio century and it's not
just because John means biologist it's
because biology even this year already
is the biggest science that we have it
gets it there's the biology gets the
most funding as the most scientists
working at it has the most results being
published it has the most economic value
it's the most ethically and culturally
important and I think it has the most to
learn from ok I think there's actually
more information in biology for us to
extract out of than there is in physics
ok so the difference is is that while
physics is very deep
it hasn't been changing over four
billion years exactly the same physics
as it was from the beginning of time
till now
whereas biology has had four billion
years of investing huge amount of energy
into making very very complex and full
of information it's very informational a
dense and so it's it it's it's a huge
treasure trove of things that we don't
know this third thing I would say is
that computers are going to lead to a
third way of science and let me take a
few minutes to explain what that means
traditionally there was two ways to the
two pillars of science was measurement
and hypothesis so you you take data and
you have ideas about it was and you
would the two would sort of feed and
test each other and in the measurement
field we're going to see more and more
data okay right now there's nothing
growing faster on this planet than
information
okay the there was a study that Hal
Varian and Peter Lyman did it at
Berkeley where they measured the growth
of information the total amount of
information in the world and the
information is growing at 66% a year
okay that dwarfs adores any other thing
that we can measure in terms of its
growth over over a very long term over a
decade say I mean iPod sales may go up
200 200 thousand or something or two
percent in a year but that's this very
short term but over decades decades the
only thing that we can measure that's
growing that fast is is the intangibles
of information now what's interesting
about 66% which I don't have a good
explanation for is that basically is
Moore's law okay so right now
information is the fastest-growing thing
and so we have we have data coming
coming off and if we take the history of
data the different in the different
thresholds is that first the first thing
that came along with precision more more
precise ways to measure then we had new
spectrums new new varieties to measure
then they were from new sources like
cameras and other kinds of tools and we
also have more durations to because we
can get data all the time we can run
these longer and longer okay and so in
some sense right now we're filling out
the entire globe with sensors it's
getting a body in terms of having ears
sound and all this data is flowing in
and that's what we're headed towards is
this humungous flow of data I just threw
up a couple of of instances of the
growth in data and I called zillions
because there's zillions of bits there's
zillions of everything and dealing with
zillions of things is actually difficult
we don't I mean
requires kind of a new set of parameters
and perspectives to deal with ilion's of
stuff and that's what we're talking
about
also is this is giving eclipse very fast
because I noticed that there was one
terabyte well I just bought a one
terabyte hard disk two weeks ago and
I've already filled it up it's with
videos digitizing videos from home
movies so terabytes you know we're going
very fast we're headed into into another
realm with this the second pillar of
classical science with hypothesis
learning where where you you you you
were going to try and make a theory you
were going to try and structure
something not just measure it and that
will always work off in tandem with with
observation well some of the things that
coming along that are in the new science
coming down is dealing with them all
matrices of multiple hypotheses so
instead of having a serial 1 we have an
apotheosis you try it out you go along
you you entertain multiple ones at the
same time and you actually try to
navigate through and so things can be
kind of partially true and partially
incorrect and you kind of go through all
the possibilities at once another way to
do another way is is you actually kind
of what we call comet aerial sweep is
you go through the possibility space you
explore the the all possible
arrangements before computers this was
impossible but now we can kind of do
this on a mass scale and this is an
example of if Steven Wolfram's going
through see a space and looking at all
possible CAS as a way to try understand
what the general behavior of CAS were
rather than doing one experiment and one
at a time and we use combination
combinatorial search and lots of things
we're going going making huge libraries
of possibilities and we chemistry's or
chemicals new ceramics found that way
rare earths pharmacology large molecules
synthesis and multiple hypothesis
operating all at once
now the third variety that we haven't
had is simulations that was not until
1946 and this is a big thing we do huge
again huge simulations and what's
interesting about the huge simulations
is that they generate huge amounts of
data and the bigger and more complex and
they're realer and more sophisticated
they are
the more data that the simulation itself
is generating not the observation so we
have a move now to where I think that
most of the data that we're going to be
generating it's probably going to be
coming from simulations and not from
observation that the simulation data
will actually dwarf the real data not
real data but the observational data so
these three things the three things are
in the step two now we have a tripod of
three different kinds of science and
they're feeding off each other in in
kind of a new way so this three of where
you have assimilation which will in some
ways inspire measurement and other times
the measurements and will aspire a
simulation or you have a hypothesis and
assimilation the two of them working
against each other where you have a
hypothesis and you try it out simulation
the simulation informs that pathes so
now there's a serve a triangle in three
different ways three different pillars
and I call this sort of intersection of
the three I call that deep science
because it is it is a it is a is a
different way of doing science where
where what you imagine a placement as an
important point it's what you measure
so there and show you how there's three
little patterns where maybe in say you
take real time measurement vast amounts
of quantity and can it can it can inform
a really deep simulation which can then
go out and inform hypothesis and those
three can be working together you can do
the same thing in the Health Sciences
again where you continuous real-time
measurement of body functions give the
process in assimilation of the body
itself which can then go and work with
different computer aided theorems about
what's happening and in environmental
science is the same thing we see the
same triad of deep science so this third
way of science which is really being
propelled by computers well maybe we can
think of it this way maybe it's this
this is the third way of science I'm not
sure where where we have how there but
it's it's it's a way in which
Computers are changing the fourth way I
think that science is gonna change the
next hundred years is science we again
create new ways of knowing an example of
that would be wiki science large scales
numbers of people involved in an
experiment I talking to a editor of
science journal recently and they were
saying they were expecting the first
1,000 author paper to come in this year
okay was that the Hadron Collider and
Europe 1000 authors well there's nothing
that's just the beginning of very very
large experiments that can be done and
maybe even experiments that aren't
finished they're sort of like a
Wikipedia where you continually are
adding on to it over time there is no
beginning or end it's like one of those
encyclopedia articles done by many many
people all at once another interesting
thing has compiled negative results
negative results are what happens when
you try to experiment it doesn't work
normally that information is thrown away
there's no reason to why it should be
thrown away because the fact it's very
very important but who's going to read
it all well if you have algorithmic or
you have you have ways in which you can
automate the processing of the negative
results it can become very very valuable
and if two things have happened when is
I discovered there actually is a journal
that's publishing negative results the
important ones they feel are important
and secondly the new journals in the
medical field where negative results are
often very critical have decided not to
accept a papers who did not register and
therefore showed that they basically I'm
Sue's me and we say that differently in
there's clinical trials and often that
the negatives also happened very early
on and a pharmacological company has no
reason to report them but now a medical
journal will not allow their final
results to be published unless they
register and let them know the early
results so this is a way to basically
enforce the large-scale habitual
recording and processing of negative
results AI computer proofs this is a
Kepler's conjecture which was around
from 1590 I think
about how to pack oranges it was only
recently approved with the aid of well
it was proved with the aid of a computer
and also the proof of it required a
computer to prove it so no human really
understands this sufficiently to be able
to prove it or to verify the proof and I
think we'll see more of that as well
triple blind emergent trials is an idea
that if you take enough data all the
time and then and and and and it's an in
non-evasive enough and you have
statistically have enough people
involved you can actually wretchedly go
back and extract out your controls you
can actually you can actually do a
specifically to say that so in this
sense neither the person involved nor
the experimenters were aware at the time
of the experiment the experiment was
going on so distributed experiments this
is another idea again this is Paul
Allen's distributed telescope which is
the fast cheap and out of control idea
which is that lots of little things
hooked together lots of small
experiments worked together lots of
small pieces of equipment lots of small
sensors together can it in aggregate
become very very powerful and in the
past these ideas never made sense
because the transactional costs were so
steep that it really didn't make sense
but now and again we have an example
after example proving how this mob crowd
hive mind distributed bits can actually
total up to be something very very
important and I think was the same thing
will happen with science and again the
last thing is the return of the
subjective this recursive coming around
which says that science is for all time
been trying to push out this objective
and remain objective to Satan to
distance itself from the subjective
experience but when you get down to the
very bottoms of things in the very
largest of things where things get
really weird it's actually necessary to
come back to a subjective and I think
that we'll see a return of this
objective in some of the most basic
things like quantum
affects that that it's almost
inescapable that not to bring in that
that recursive loop back into the
equation we don't have very good tools
but how to how to do that scientifically
but I think that's what will involve so
the fifth and last way I think science
will change the next hundred years is
that will create a new level of meaning
and what do I mean by that only this
that if we take this citation map which
I showed before this is a much deeper
one that's showing in the chemical
journals all the authors who are
referencing other authors it's their map
of influences and how facts are related
and proved and tested against each other
that is a very recursive net and this is
actually a map of the Internet this is
I'm showing the KY major trunk lines and
there's I think Asia is red and North
America is blue it's a pretty current
image of the full interconnection and
recursive nature of the Internet and I
think what's happening is is that this
is becoming one machine and then why
don't and I don't know it really treated
this seriously as if it was a machine if
you had all the computers in the world
hooked up through the internet and you
actually totaled summed up their specs
what would you have well you can read
that here 1 billion PC chips 1 million
emails per second 1 million I am
messages per second 8 tarababu
so say well that's a very interesting
computer ok that's that's a pretty big
computer and actually I did some other
things and I figured out here's if we
were selling us on Amazon it would be a
trillion dollars and hey we've got 1
billion trips 1 megahertz email Kate so
that's interesting it's and what's
interesting about that this one computer
that we're making is that it's actually
approaching the complexity of of a brain
so here here this is again this is other
if you take all the transistors and all
the pcs in the whole world connected
together there's a quick
you know them if you take all the web
pages there are all the ones in the deep
web pages on average they have about 15
links on each page there's a trillion
links which you can see it as a synapse
as in a brain just 20 peda hurts of
Sinop firings that's the speed at which
the thing fires and there's 20 exabyte
of memory that's a--that's a very big
machine that's that's approaching the
complexity of the human brain it's about
100 it's about two orders off but the
thing about the thing about the Internet
is its doubling every year and the
brains not doing that okay so I think
and if we add our own brains at the
other end of that we have a very large
machine and this machine is actually
what's doing science now this is this
new structuring of information and
knowledge is the thing that is now doing
science and a lot of people are kind of
worried about that because you've heard
Ray Kurzweil suggestion that this once
this happens that would just take off
and the technology and will accelerate
into a singularity I think the single
arity is actually an illusion I think
that I think that it doesn't happen from
I mean I think that the technology
acceleration is true is valid but I
think the idea that we're gonna go
through something that will change and
it be a discontinuity is not is one of
my favorite New Yorker cartoons for
those who who can't see in the back it's
the guys coming in from lunch after a
long lunch and he coming in and his very
perky secretary is waving a little memo
she says sir the following paradigm
shifts occurred while you were out I
think I think that that what happens is
that we've already been through several
of these large-scale lifting up of new
levels of meaning this emergent thing
where things come back and they come up
but we didn't even notice it here's
another cartoon
two guys of the cave saying hey anyone
notes that we're using language we never
did that because that was a language was
a single arity but we went through it
without any noticing it just as we'll go
through this one machine this this large
corpus of the new thing that's doing
science it's an infinite game we raise
up to the new level and the level
connects and restructures in such a way
that lifts up to another level so one of
the things I think that science does not
do which is a very common idea is that
it seeks after truth that's what people
say ideas famous scientist said that's
what science is always seeking after
truth and actually I don't think that's
I don't think that's true these are is
the true of course mathematics
it doesn't change but there are lots of
things that we know about science or we
think we know that is not true over time
even the idea that the world is round
well find out the world's not really
perfectly round is kind of it's off and
then maybe in another dimension is not
round so even facts like that will what
change over time so I don't think it's
actually what truth is that that that
what science is really after there's
interesting thing about discovery and
invention which is that when you have
enough choices when it went whether the
big the field is big enough when there's
enough variables when the degrees of
freedom are sufficient that the
distinction between discovery and
invention are nil that they're basically
equivalent it's the same act we can kind
of see that it is a picture of some
biological forms and we can say well
evolution or nature did they invent
those or discover those but we see if we
understand that there were equivalent
ideas so we could say in the same way
that Edison discovered the light bulb he
didn't really invented he discovered it
or the Benjamin Franklin invented
electricity
we could say that Pythagorean Pythagoras
invented the Pythagorean theorem
okay so in the same way that I think the
difference between knowing and creating
is also equivalent there's an
equivalency and knowing is not passive
as I'm suggesting it's a constructive
thing we're constructing knowledge and
knowing is a constructive creative act
and in that way the process of changing
how we know provides us with
possibilities so I think this is
actually what science is about clients
is about possibilities it's about
differences options choices freedoms
diversity that's what science generates
in us if we go back to this hany model
of the internet and we see all these
things here imagine if those all those
this is a space of possibilities of
different organisms all the species on
earth and this was the the possibility
space and what what of course science is
trying to do is we're trying to explore
and reach all those possibilities so in
some ways it's it's infinite ways to
play the infinite game we can go back to
the same the same map of these things
and we can say well now imagine if these
were actually the different ways in
which you could be a person imagine that
these are different a map of the
possibility of space of all the ways
that a person could be born the various
you know introverts are over here a
traverse a kind of you know there's a
very complex high dimension way in which
the the gifts and talents of different
people were mapped and so what I think
what science is in part about is trying
to uncover and reach and have us arrive
at those places that would provide the
knowledge and tools for every person to
fulfill their full potential so I like
to imagine what would be like if Mozart
had been born before the piano had been
invented what a loss that would be or if
you imagine then go having been born
before oil-paint was invented the option
of oil paints or Hitchcock before film
and so I think right now there today
this is my son Tywin I think there are
children today or born whose thing whose
science whose technology does not exist
yet they're they're going to live and
die without having us having provided
collectively the thing for them and I
think that's a great shame in some way I
think we have a moral obligation to
actually go out and discover and seek
and make all those possibilities and
that's it so that people can play this
infinite game while I was searching
around for the origins of science I
found a very interesting quote the very
very very first use of the word science
I could find in English language was in
1340 and it was called four gods of fir
God of Sciences Lord I'm not sure what
it means but it was interesting that it
was being there because I think I want
to come back to the fact that the two
entities that we know how to make the
two entities that generate infinite
games or science and religion and I find
interesting that that at the bottom of
most religions and most beliefs in God
or the universe is basically this
recursive loop I mean you can't get out
of it we're the beginning of the
universe who made the universe well the
universe always was God who made God if
and so you have that you have the sense
in which in which a kind of connecting
to itself is the origin of everything
that there is a paradox at the very
basis of it and I think what science
about for myself the science is the way
we surprised God that's what we're here
for that's what science is is it's a way
for us to surprise God now you might
think that's kind of strange but think
about like second life you know what's
what's cooler is it the have a game
where you make everything in there
or to have a game we're all sufficiently
sufficiently deep enough where the
players themselves these entities not
with people there but the robots you
make the Box you make are actually going
to surprise you as the Creator I mean
which programmers which programmers
superior is the it's the program where
the creation actually completes the
creation and I think that's part of what
we have with this idea that we're taking
all the possibilities and I think it
goes even further than that imagine that
this is a possibility space of all the
possible ways to know ok all the
possible ways to know all the possible
ways to be smart all the possible ways
to find out things all the way all the
possible ways to to think so I think
we'll take all the possible species of
intelligence in order for the universe
to understand itself ok so so the
universe cannot understand itself until
we have all the possible my all the
possible ways to to structure that
knowledge another way of saying the way
I would say it is that will take all
puffs of minds in the universe to know
the mind of God and so for that reason
for that reason I think science is holy
I think is I think it's this I think
it's a holy act I think it's a holy work
and I think that the long-term future of
science is actually a divine trip thank
you a weapon questions
Divine Right strip I'm slow getting up
here just says scribbling notes as fast
as I possibly question from Saul
Griffith where are you Saul somewhere
out there there wait there is okay well
we still need hypothesis if we have
sufficiently granular observation and
post observation analysis interesting
question
III can't I can't imagine us not having
up offices I think that would be the
problem is we may not need it but we
would have them and other interesting
thing about science my observing of
scientists is that there's two type
there are some scientists who work from
data first and there are a lot of
scientists who do what you're not
supposed to do which is they have the
theory first and then they go look for
data to fill it that's not supposed to
happen but that happens a lot and it's
actually very fruitful so I think that
even though we don't need it for many
people they'll find that it's actually
useful way to work not many on the
history but here's a good 100 years ago
in 1906 this is from Ken where's Ken
wave your hand back right over there
in 1906 what was expected then from the
next 100 years I don't know I don't know
that would be a great question to to get
a view of the future from 1906 well yeah
flying cars jetpacks anti-gravity but
the interesting thing about the
expectations of science is that there
are argh and there's two sets of
inventions there's a set of invention
that were predicted and then there was a
set of inventions that were not and
actually had some discussions with Danny
Hillis about this I think the ones that
were particular was that we could easily
visualize I mean visually see in our
mind things like like x-rays and atomic
fusion were not because it was
very hard to visualize so I I think that
that may be my second answer second
thought answer to your question might be
that in 1906 three probably things that
were easy to see in our mind the picture
that would be an interesting list by the
way yeah we have in your book Jesus yeah
sort of foreseeable and non-for see
exactly discoveries and inventions Scot
Bergquist as a question right over here
where does the competitiveness
competitiveness of warfare the
laboratory of the battlefield fit under
your view of the progression of science
there's a science whoria of steel canned
food I asked production it's a major
funder of it I would say III think I
mean even now in the US a lot of
interesting work is done through the
excuse that it's military-related
III other than that I mean I think I
think people piggyback off of it and
maybe scientists are sometimes not as
truthful or as brave in refusing it
because it's oftentimes a way to get
money the people banking on the fear of
militarism and they'll say well I can at
least fund my work and that does happen
a lot what if piece breaks out and we
have a peaceful century question that's
a good question
I would hope not but I don't know that's
a good question I don't I don't know
well in a sense this raises you're
putting recursiveness is the core issue
with answer and with the net society or
civilization itself is increasingly
recursive right and so are we now
reaching a point where recursion is
potentially replacing competitiveness
what could drive science and so we don't
need war or we don't need even
commercial competition make it go
forward I actually believe that we don't
that we actually can live with that war
that we can actually have a war list
planet I mean I really do believe that
and and and I'm not a pacifist I'm a
police official Isa fist I believe in
and the rule of law you know it's
interesting that the only pacifist we
know we're pacifists passive hasn't got
any happening in in cultures where
there's of the rule of law Jesus was in
the Romans
you know Gandhi was the British Thoreau
and Martin Luther King were in the u.s.
there were no pacifists in the mungo and
the Mongols
there's no Stu think as a Mongolian
pacifist at that time so not for long
right so it's actually when you do this
second third fourth we get a different
interesting space
Kurt Stoddard were you waiting back what
is the current status and near-term
prospects of the old species prose is
progress still occurring in small-scale
projects and who was the current point
of contact all species project for those
who don't know is that it was a campaign
to find discover name catalog every
living species on earth in 25 years to
give you a scale of that challenge we
know we don't even know how many species
we don't know about so the estimates of
how many total species on earth range
between five to thirty to a million
species depending on how you want to
count bacterium and we do know fact we
don't even know how many we know that
the numbers of species there are known
ranges between 1.6 1.7 and a lot of them
are duplicates so it was a big big big
project we didn't get very far
we were hoping to have some of the money
from individuals which which did not
happen however the most recent stirrings
I hear are from Google where this seems
to be a kind of a perfect Google project
in terms of making a big database it has
huge numbers of information and we'll
see you if anything happens there but
right now it's stuck in the water
although craig Venter who finished the
genome is now
to try and do the genomes of bacterium
in the sea and that's actually a
probably a much better way to try to
identify things and he's actually doing
straight ahead just go and do it so
there is some work being done in trying
to just massively take everything that
you can scoop up and to identify it with
DNA an update on craig Venter I talked
to him last week at a conference and
sort of you know like what are you doing
next because he saw has got some next
thing create life or whatever currently
he is looking for potentially extra
planetary organisms at the edge of space
and doing the same kind of shotgun
sequencing way out at the outside of the
stratosphere as he's been doing out in
the middle of the oceans great and you
know depending on what Trent's up there
he may get a sense of everything is
earthly or maybe not what's your bet
sorry what's your bet well my bet is
well remember there's an actual long bet
on the subject of where life not from
the earth will be discovered and Freeman
Dyson about a thousand dollars that will
be discovered somewhere than on the
surface of another planet if it's
discovered in our outer atmosphere does
that count
he will win that bet I think yeah I
wouldn't be surprised either way
possibility space is big there someone
with the name from the future named
Karthik who's actually time-traveling
says how do you think language is
indebted to science I feel that a lack
or is limiting on sense it feel the lack
of a single language hinders to the
development of science many people's
ideas are lost due to the lack of
expressing it in a way that everybody
else can understand I dunno if I'm
hanging around for being a science
groupie that scientists are really
horrible communicators and so I could
III could see that becoming a problem
and that's I did a recent study of the
language on the web and was shocked to
find out that
third of the web pages are not in
English it was and two-thirds of the
people are not the English native
English speakers
most of the the Chinese of course are
just overwhelming the way of like
anything else and so I think the
prospects of a single language that
everybody speaks maybe English but it'll
be the second language for most people
and then I I also believe that the
machine translation at some point or
other will really facilitate the
language issue in terms of different
languages if that's what the person
meant if it means just communication
that's always a problem for for
scientists so pretty soon I would expect
based on what you've been saying already
not only will we get machine translation
but machine improvement so now that you
know translate what was said it'll make
it better than it was originally I want
that on my machine and this relates to a
question from unnamed do you think
Sciences failed to explain itself to the
greater public and is this why the
theory of evolution is receiving less
respect now and while you're at it what
do you think about quote intelligent
design as a Christian yeah I'm missing
about intelligent design one thing is I
think that in a kind of curious way I
think the intelligent design movement or
I should I'm hopeful that the
intelligent design will have more effect
on the fundamentalist than on anyone
else and that is is that it's a step in
the right direction so if Christians
will accept intelligent design then it's
a easier step and I think in fact that
that in the long term a long term this
will not be an issue that it's just
simply going to go away this is my
feeling I think it's this is a little
bit like contraception and the Catholics
there was there was everyone you know
thought that all the Catholics were
obeying what the Pope said but in real
life they weren't and I and it's
actually very similar I think even in
the angelical circles people who people
privately believe in evolution but don't
but this go along with it and don't
aren't following even what's being said
from the pulpit I think you're actually
is some data on that was research was
done the last year or so comparing high
school classes where evolution was
taught straight and versus where
evolution was taught teach the
controversy where the both evolution and
intelligent design were undertaken and
to my astonishment is a biologist the
teach the controversy one worked out
better in this sense that in both cases
the people who thought evolution was
what was happening got evolution nobody
was you know didn't right yeah
Darwin but in the case where the
controversy was taught the
fundamentalists or the people who had
doubts about evolution came out of the
class with belief in it and you can
imagine it was way more fun to talk
about in class and that you know
evolution is not a given it's probably a
good way to teach all kinds of science
that would be interesting reinvent
science teaching is it's all
controversial okay here's a question
representing a lot of questions this one
version happens to be from Matthew
Dean's way over there I think or is that
someone scratching their head when will
we see the first zero author paper all
that stuff basically is offering things
on their own and you know the citation
just fails yes when well this is all
timing and I think that I think we will
but I don't have any idea when maybe
others here who are working on it might
know but I don't it's a great idea zero
authors good stevewall Rob
how a scientific progress possible
without a sustainable civilization huh
say at this point where we're basically
right now down to one variegated but
pretty much overlapping civilization III
think it's it's not really possible
because well I think you you would have
a science a very primitive science you'd
have to retreat to something very
elementary and you would you would lose
the the depth
I mean basically the infrastructure that
we have for science right now is
phenomenal and it's not just of course
scientists it's is the communication
pathways it's you know it's this life
support it's it's is vast underpinning
and so I think it would be really very
tough for science as we have now evolved
it to continue I think my point is is
that there are very different kinds of
science just as there are different
kinds of evolution people don't realize
that people think there's only evolution
but evolution itself has evolved and so
in the beginning of life evolution was
very different than it is now there's
horizontal gene transfer which is very
different than what goes on right now
and so well we're doing horizontal we're
going to in fact in fact Freeman Dyson
calls it the Darwinian interlude where
there was massive horizontal gene
transfer long ago then there was a
couple billion years of non horizontal
and now we're gonna go back to
horizontal gene transfer on a massive
scale as we swap genes and everything
under the Sun dan Simon asks is science
moving too fast for the long now if so
how can it be slowed down and by the way
should it be slowed down right I don't I
don't think so I I think the speed I
think what happens if we are going to
change I think we ourselves our concept
our cells our bodies and again I think
as I'm suggesting the science is not
being done just by humans is being done
by this machine it's it's it's it can
operate at a level that's not even our
level and so I don't think so
is slowing down and I think of course
this is substantial architecture in the
sense that we continue to do our thing
and you have multiple levels things
operate in multiple scales and multiple
speeds and so I think the news bead will
be added on to the current speed but I
don't see it slowing down at all so this
relates to a question from Phillip
Phillips obviously a fictional name is
science really unidirectional and it's
the expansion er can this be reversed by
a forces of religion and politics could
you could you say is the science really
unidirectional and its expansion that is
does it always expand or can it be
driven I tried basically legislated fear
or whatever you know I mean I haven't
take a parallel view of science they do
of life and what's interesting about
life is that as far as I know is never
retreated from wherever it's gone there
are certain species of life that
obviously have gone extinct but once
life in info trails any environment at
all it never leaves I mean life is down
in the rocks in inside the earth you ask
a hospital a hospital
you know triose is sterilized it cannot
sterilize her a room really so I think
the same thing with science I think
there will be species of science certain
methods certain varieties of science
that may retreat but I think overall
it's a very progressive force that does
not retreat as long as the the whole
thing is going please clarify how you
distinguish between the future of
science and the future of technology
that's a good question I think I think
science is a sort of a way of thinking
and then the technology is sort of like
this fruiting body it's kind of made
real it's a thought made concrete you
know in a sense of having not
necessarily a mass but it's something
that have bad that has boundaries and so
I think there's a very blurred overlap
between science and technology as our
technology becomes more intangible so I
think that the distinction is something
that is starting to blur and it was
maybe over time we won't have the same
the same distinction science is a
process of how things change and how we
change our knowing and I think
technology for now right now something
that it's throws off it's like a science
is sort of like a brain and then the
technologies like the ideas that it has
but of course science itself can be
ideas so I think there is a distinction
but I think over time they'll become
less how much is science itself
technology driven well I think
everything I mean I I think science the
tools of science the the the the the the
tools of science allow new questions
allowing new data so I think it's very
very technology driven that I think you
can make more difference in science by
inventing a really great new tool than a
great new theory what isn't science asks
Eric Lloyd what isn't science what what
what is what is not science where's not
science religion you were getting well
kind of converging like what's the great
distinction between science and religion
I think I think that and I think I think
religion has more of a sense of values
for humans in terms of of what choices
you want to make and I think science has
less of that I think science is less
about humans and more about the general
drift of evolution throughout the
universe and the the you know is I don't
think science cares were very much about
humans and I think it's a human oriented
endeavor actually and how does religion
care about you
I think I think religions is is what
humans care about in certain sense in a
sense of its it's about our relationship
to the universe it's where it's trying
to do this it's a method for
understanding where we fit into the
universe as knowledge is expanded it
takes each young person a longer time to
learn it or even learn to navigate it
will this limit future generations
ability to contribute new science well
the solution so far has been you
specialize in too small so you know more
and more about less and less which sort
of evens things out so no III think
that's that's what happens I think that
we that we are basically science is
about expanding ignorance this goes back
to my idea that science is not about
truth what happens is that a really good
question in science will unleash 20 or
30 other new questions and so if you're
really doing science well you're you're
you're expanding the field of what you
don't know in fact the field of what
you're don't know is expanding faster
than what you're learning and so I I
think I think the speed it was just
happens in the lifetime doesn't really
make much difference that there's still
plenty to occupy a person and that you
don't have to know the entire field to
make great progress you can you can pick
something that's very very particular
what do you think of Jim Lovelock's idea
of noticing that more and more of the
science literature is more and more
about less and less and infinite
specialization that goes on and there's
no manual as sort of starting over
suppose a great big pandemic and
everything shuts down and then again
after a period of time people looking at
the kind of papers that you've been
citing here will not have the faintest
idea what that's about right
should there be a compendium maybe a
Wikipedia that like opinion but
basically all science starting with how
to make a fire yep yeah actually I
proposed something called the forever
book now forever book is a book when you
open up that tells you
exactly how to make that book okay so it
gives you tell you how to make ink kind
of make paper to print and so it gives
you the entire recipe to make that book
so it's a forever book because anybody
picks it up could make another one just
like it and I think you could have the
same thing with kind of a forever
library where the library told you how
to make the form of a library that was
in and you could have various you can
think of these as seeds for civilization
so you can have various kinds of seeds
you have a seed that would require a
certain environment in order for it to
be reconstituted so I think it's
actually it's a great idea and an
exercise to to imagine the different
ways in which you could kind of
basically compact or reduce the
essentials and and and and have it so
the unpacks in a viable way depending on
the on the the emergency so they'd be
one emergency if all i've goes off and
the other one if you want to go to the
Mars whether you don't have the biology
to to depend on another one if there's a
Dark Age of some sort and each of these
would have a different kind of a seed
that would on that you could rebuild
from it sounds like a long now project
yes let's do that
let's do that beware this is how all of
the things we do your clocks and stuff
came about eight why not generally Jax
asked what is going to be the last
question you say science is not trying
to find truth how would you define truth
and does it exist actually I mean what I
was trying to just is I think that we
actually construct truth that it is a
construction that that in fact that that
that Ben Franklin actually in the
certain way did invent electricity and
that Pythagoras did invent the theorem
and that there's a there's a father I
think his name is Brian Cantwell Smith
who said the electron always existed
from the time of Rutherford
and I so so III I'm much I think it
actually what we know as truth is
basically a a convergence of many
different connections that we seem to
that boys us up there's actually
something we construct and and you know
my you know do atoms exist do I think
Adams exists yes I mean but but my
evidence for that is so abstract it's
dependent on so many other connections
that I would say yes it's true that
atoms exist but but I have to I have to
rest on a very large network of other
things to support that and so my sense
of what's true is is in way constructed
so is it the case of Rutherford and
discovered what he discovered but not
told anybody the electron wouldn't be
existed until somebody else I think so I
think it does not exist until does not
always exist does not always exist until
it's actually become something that
other people agree on truth is an
agreement I think it's a I think it's
less an agreement they're more something
that's the construction I think it's
something that I think we do in a
certain sense make what we think is real
well yeah exactly it's one of the
questions and did great lecture thank
you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]